hi Peter can you hear me
hot APC my name's Samuel I think we just
missed each other a couple of times but
great to speak I was just calling about
your your apartment that you've got on I
saw it on gumtree so it looks good I
think you said that the I was looking at
the pictures I think does it come
furnished okay fantastic and it's on for
nine hundred and fifty pounds per
calendar month is that right all right
awesome fantastic so basically my
situation is okay that's all right
no worries hi Peter speech in a minute
okay so course I said to someone I still
AM how to find rent to rent deals went
to service accommodation deals I said
someone just give me an area and someone
shouted out Belfast which is obviously
not even in this country Belfast in
Ireland so I went on Belfast went on
gumtree saw a really really nice
apartment landlords details direct just
come on gumtree
I just found her he didn't answer and I
said I just left a message I said I my
name is Sammy I've got company
but did you corporate let's see if
that's something you're open to give me
a call back he phoned me back while I'm
on stage now we're on a short break
Alistair's did someone stays with just
nipped ow I'm gonna talk to him and
we're telling what I'm doing secure the
deal right here right there booked the
viewing and see what happens and
I mean I could spend hours and hours
teaching people the theory but will you
find at my programs is we don't do
theory which is practical it's like
something you'd learn to drive you've
got to just get in the car and drive so
that's what we do now so hopefully
they'll come it's a bit of a bad line
they'll call you back in a second so no
loss of community but I need to tell you
up front when I'm booking the doing I'm
going to be doing it as a rent to rent
serviced accommodation in other words
it's a corporate letter company laughs
so yeah man see what happens exciting
times so I'd love to have a look around
your your apartment it looks really nice
and I love the fact that it's furnished
and the location is absolutely fantastic
are you the landlord do you own the
apartment nice nice that's not a bad
investment for you have you got more
than one in the block or is it just that
one you've got okay nice fantastic so um
so basically yes I've got a company so
it would be a corporate lat I don't know
if that's something that you'd you've
done before with this particular
property but I could look round um I
could do Tuesday or Thursday next week
if either of those are any good Tuesday
okay what time 3:00 o'clock works that's
fine okay cool I know where it is
because I've got the I've got the
adjustable past if you could just text
over the exact address and then just
confirmation and I'll see you at 3:00
o'clock on Tuesday
no I wouldn't be living there myself
that's why I've got a company but yeah I
mean we can talk through that when I see
you as well I would work but I've got
we've got quite a few apartments that I
company rent so as far as as far as as
far as we're concerned 950 is fine so we
could just pay that I make it fixed you
know fixed return so yeah happy days
yeah so my name is Samuel Leeds and the
company's Samuel Leeds limited no we
were actually got a real estate business
I mean if you if you google me you'll
see quite a lot of your phone you'll
pull up quite a lot of information so
feel free to you know check me out
online
by all means yes yeah all right that's
great I'll look for to meeting you Peter
on Tuesday at 3 o'clock thank you so
much hey just Google the company it does
help so that means I would have to fly
to Belfast or ferry to Belfast on
Tuesday or have to arrange for someone
else to go decisions decisions now I
have a new problem you're always you
know Paul's in your life
the hammer going to view it what kind of
contract only is one just take off each
bridge as it goes first thing first
problem is finding a landlord
there's happy to do a rent to serviced
accommodation a corporate that agreement
he's happy to do it now I have a new
problem
how am I gonna get there I'll figure
that out then have a new problem and
it's just walking the ABC rather than
trying to work out the XYZ all the time
so yeah man I'm documenting see what
happens but that is in the prime
location in Belfast I think I can make a
lot of money on that maybe service
accommodation and I found that on stage
at the crash course